una parada en la carrera por encontrar
una vacuna contra el kobe 19
la farmacéutica sueco británica
astrazéneca anunció la suspensión de los
ensayos clínicos globales de la
potencial inyección que está
desarrollando junto con la universidad
de oxford debido a que uno de los
voluntarios sufrió una enfermedad
inesperada según la portavoz de la
empresa esta es una acción rutinaria que
tiene que ocurrir siempre que haya una
enfermedad potencialmente inexplicable
en uno de los ensayos mientras se
investiga asegurando que mantenemos la
integridad de los ensayos el gran
estudio de astrazéneca es una de las
tres vacunas que se encuentran más
desarrolladas con ensayos en fase 3 la
última etapa lo que significa que están
siendo testadas en miles de personas en
varios continentes la noticia llegó el
mismo día en que nueve de los
principales desarrolladores de vacunas
de eeuu y europa se comprometieron a
mantener la seguridad científica y las
normas de eficacia de sus vacunas
experimentales pese a la urgencia por
contener la pandemia y ante la
preocupación de que los estándares de
seguridad pudieran no cumplirse ante la
presión política en relación con los
comicios presidencia
y estadounidenses de noviembre lo que
quiero decir es que en este compromiso
todas las compañías están diciendo que
sólo nos someteremos a la autorización
cuando tengamos pruebas de seguridad y
eficacia que provengan de un estudio de
fase 3 bien diseñado
el anuncio provocó que las acciones de
la empresa cayeran hasta un 83 por
ciento en nueva york mientras que los
títulos de sus principales competidoras
modernas y la alemana avión tech
subieron levemente